this proposal is thoughtful it's
comprehensive
I would even use the term bold but it's
almost too good to be true right because
on the one hand it doesn't mess with
Social Security
it's deficit-neutral the returns are
guaranteed and it pays income for life
after retirement in a nutshell how does
it work okay so every working American
would would have a account and 3% of his
earnings would be put in that account
one and a half from the worker and one
half percent percent from the employer
those savings would be invested over the
life of the well were the career of the
worker and at the end they'd be
converted to an annuity where we should
give them a lifelong income it's very
simple but it's very powerful because
you get their earnings on those savings
for 4050 years whatever the life of a
career is and it's the earnings on those
savings which which fund a lot of the
shortfall there are lots of people who
will say hey wait a second I've got a
401k I don't need a guaranteed
retirement account the GRA that you've
proposed why is this better than a 401k
well a few reasons first of all 401ks
are inefficient those assets have to be
invested in in liquid securities only
because the the holder could pull the
money out secondly human nature being
what it is people do pull the money out
they pay the penalties and then they
they spend it unwisely thirdly it
doesn't convert to an annuity at the end
and fourth only half of working
Americans that don't have pension plans
have 401ks anyway the other half has
nothing so and then part and then I
think very importantly the fifth reason
is for for people below median income
they don't have the savings to put in
the 401k and our plan re repurposes the
the tax deductions that affluent savers
get for the 401 K and gives it to the
people below me an income and this chart
that we have here explains graphically
how it would work you accumulate savings
the savings are superior because of the
kinds of because the non liquid
investments then what you can get out of
a 401 K and then buy annuitize me and
you make sure
that there is no drop-off right right
and so as long as as long as you and
your spouse live you'll have that
constant income so furthermore the
proposal says that these savings the
retirement savings can be achieved with
no tax increase at no cost to
lower-income households and with little
to no additional expense for most
employers that leaves an obvious
question who's going to pay for this
thing okay so the importantly we're
repurposing a hundred and twenty billion
of tax deductions that go to affluent
savers when they make their a plural and
K contribution and repurposing that and
giving all Peet workers up to $600 a
year credit against their contributions
into the savings plan that $600 a year
will pay for the savings for people
meeting and coming below so we're really
taking taking we're moving that money
around and that's that's an important
underwriting for for so you're taking
what economists would call a regressive
system and turning it into a progressive
system that's true but affluent people
view I think those contributions to the
401 K where you have to itemize
deductions to get it they view that as
more tax management than funding their
retirement they they tend to have enough
money that they're not this isn't gonna
be what they're gonna retire on anyway
so it's not really serving the purpose
that it was set up for there are other
ways for affluence our a fluent people
to save taxes Tony I know you want this
proposal to be taken seriously you put a
lot of time and effort into it so let's
take care of a couple of arguments or
some people might call them accusations
if you prefer that potentially stand in
the way of that happening here's one
you're conflicted right the proposal
makes the case for longer term illiquid
investments such as hedge funds private
equity and real estate the very same
assets currently managed by your firm
the Blackstone Group right and because
we manage the money we know what the
returns can be earned but let's be clear
if this gets enacted there are going to
be thousands and thousands and thousands
of asset managers that will benefit I
suppose because more savings and more
investment benefits all asset managers
of every stripe for Blackstone
it's it's frankly small its retail and
our funds are already oversubscribed I
don't think we're gonna get much out
okay here's the second one you have
ulterior motives in other words this is
just Tony James angling for a job in
Hillary Clinton's cabinet well I've
certainly am NOT doing that I love what
I'm doing in it I couldn't be happier
but importantly I sit there and I deal
with retirement savings every day I can
see the problem it's crystal clear 86%
of Americans in surveys worried about
retirement security what else does 86%
of Americans in this country agree on
that's the one thing it's dominant and
no one's talking about it so from my
standpoint here you had a huge issue
huge issue shared by all Americans and
no politicians talking about it and I
felt like okay I have a seat I have some
expertise I should do something about it
I don't care whether my plan works or
not I just want this issue to be dealt
with seriously and discussed if you were
to I wonder to myself though why tackle
this issue and not any number of other
pressing issues if you were to survey 18
to 34 year olds these are the people who
are going to be who will benefit
ultimately if a plan like this is put
into place they'll tell you that the
biggest problem that they face is debt
right as a subset of that that student
that there's a trillion dollars of
unpaid outstanding student debt I would
imagine you have some good ideas for
that too I have some ideas of things he
could do about that yes but I'm not an
expert in student debt I am an expert in
in managing retirement accounts